today i've got an update on progress in
our battle against coronavirus
some new evidence of the effectiveness
of the vaccines
an update on cases of the brazilian
variant
of concern and extra funding to support
mental health
in schools because of course on monday
that marks our first step in the
opening up after this lockdown next week
classrooms will once again be
buzzing with activity and i know
that parents across england will be
delighted
and i'm sure relieved that all children
are going back to school also from
monday
i'm just so pleased that we're able to
reopen
care homes to visiting we've put in
place a really careful policy
so each care home resident will be able
to
register a single regular visitor
who'll be tested and wear ppe but be
able to visit
and i know that this means so much to
hundreds of thousands of people with a
loved one in a care home
and to those who live in care homes and
i'm really really glad that we're able
to make this step
so first let's turn to the latest
coronavirus data
and this data shows the progress we've
made including
more evidence on the impact of the
vaccine in
saving lives if i could have the first
slide please
here you can see the number of cases of
covid19 and i'm pleased to say
that the cases are still falling
the average daily number of cases is
6685 the lowest
since late september and the weekly case
rate
across the uk is now 84 per
100 000 people the latest figures from
the office for national statistics
that were published earlier today report
a further significant decline
they show that in england 1 in 220
people have coronavirus
a fall from 1 in 145
last week this is all encouraging news
and it should give us confidence
that we can safely take the steps that
we're taking on monday
next slide please slide two shows the
hospital
admissions with covid and it shows that
they are falling too
there are still 12 136 people in
hospital
in the uk with covid that's still too
high
but the average number of new admissions
to hospital is
900 the lowest since october
next slide please thankfully the number
of deaths with covid
are also declining steeply the average
number of deaths per day is 248
also the lowest since october and here
the decline is in fact
accelerating the halving time of the
number of deaths has come down
from 19 days so the number of deaths
each day
halving every 19 days last month to
halving every 11 days
now not only that there are now fewer
people dying
from all courses in care homes than is
normal for this time
of year taken together these three
slides show that we're heading in the
right direction
although that there is further to go and
what we can also see in the data
across the whole uk is that the vaccine
program
is working to protect the nhs and
saving lives if we go on to the next
slide
the best way to see this is by looking
at how fast
cases hospital admissions and deaths
are falling the number of cases have
been falling in a fairly even way
since around the middle of january and
by a quarter every week
and just a little bit more in the last
few days it's not been completely smooth
as you can see from the slide a week ago
i stood here we stood here and we
said that we were worried that the fall
in cases
was slowing down thankfully as you can
see in the chart that now looks
more like a temporary blip which is good
news for us all
next slide please now let's turn to the
number of hospital admissions
again this is falling steadily at
just under 30 percent every week but
there are signs that this fall is
getting
a bit faster as you can see from the
last week's data there
and in fact the 29 fall in the last week
is the fastest
fall in hospital admissions
at any point in the entire pandemic
if we go to the final slide please where
you can really see the effect of the
vaccine
is in the fall in the number of deaths
the number of deaths
is falling faster and faster and now
deaths are falling by
over a third each week and in fact in
the last week
have fallen by 41 they're falling faster
than before
now the chief medical officer told us
weeks ago
that you'd first see the effect of the
vaccine in fewer people dying
and then in reduced hospitalizations and
i believe that that is exactly what is
happening
what this all shows is that the link
from cases to hospitalizations and then
to deaths
that have been unbreakable before the
vaccine
that link is now breaking the vaccine is
protecting the nhs
and saving lives and right across the
country
the country's plan is working
as well as this real world data i want
to share the results of a study by the
university of bristol
which clearly shows the difference the
vaccination program is making this study
looked at all patients
over 80 who were admitted with serious
respiratory disease in bristol
and the results showed that a single
dose of both
the pfizer or the oxford astrazeneca jab
offers around 80 protection against
hospitalization
after at least two weeks even amongst
the most frail
and those with underlying medical
conditions again
as with the data on this that were
published last week
the effect was slightly stronger in the
oxford jab
than with pfizer and what this
corroborates
is what we have seen over the past
couple of weeks the
hard evidence that vaccines work
they're the best way of securing our
freedom because they're the best way of
protecting us
as of midnight last night 21.3 million
people had been vaccinated
and i can tell you for the first time
that we have vaccinated now two-fifths
of the entire adult population of the
united kingdom
yesterday i was in scotland seeing the
combined teamwork of nhs scotland and
scottish local authorities and the armed
forces
delivering jabs in hamilton and they
were all
working together as one towards a common
goal of protecting us all
and as anybody who's been to a
vaccination center will know that
the joy on people's faces as they get
the jab is
unbelievably uplifting and more and more
people
will be getting this feeling of
protection over the next few weeks and
months we're on course to hit our target
of offering a first dose to everyone
who's over 50 or part of an at-risk
group
by the 15th of april and all adults by
the end of july
the vaccine rollout has allowed us to
set out our roadmap
for how we'll carefully lift some of the
restrictions that we've all endured
for far too long and as we do this we'll
be drawing on the huge
testing infrastructure that's now in
place and i just want to spend a moment
on this we're now testing 2.8 million
people a week
the roadmap is built on the principle of
replacing the protection that comes from
lockdown
with the protection that comes from
vaccines and regular testing
so as we open up for instance care homes
as i mentioned a moment ago
to visitors that will come with regular
testing for visitors and as schools and
colleges return
we'll be giving teachers staff parents
secondary
and college students and their
households access to rapid regular
testing
twice a week in term time and in
holidays
and i urge all those and the households
of those
who are going back to school or to
college next week
to take up this offer
one of the most dangerous things about
this virus
one of the most dangerous things is that
around a third of those who get it
don't get any symptoms at all and yet
can still
pass the disease on to others that's why
it's so
important that all of us follow the
social distancing
and take the precautions that we know we
must
rapid regular testing is a critical part
of our response and as we do so much
more
we can do more because of the huge
capacity built up by nhs test and trace
so i would urge you if you're eligible
to participate in one of these
regular testing programs like i do
because that is how we will keep this
virus under control
as we continue to roll out the vaccine
for more information go to gov dot uk
forward slash
coronavirus and i'd urge everybody
who's eligible to get that regular
testing
now i know also that this pandemic has
been an anxious time for so many
young people and i just want to spend a
moment on this after all
growing up is tough enough even at the
best of times
so in these very difficult times it's
been even tougher
homeschooling being unable to meet up
with friends
not having regular sport being stuck at
home
i know just how much people are looking
forward to going back to school to
seeing
friends in a classroom properly rather
than just on zoom
monday will be a long awaited day for
many people
but for some it's also a moment of
unease and
anxiety we need to make sure we get the
help
to young people to help them get through
this
and get life going again and give them
the support that they need
we've worked hard throughout the
pandemic to make sure mental health
services stay
open we've set up 24 7 support for those
in need
and i'm delighted to be able to announce
today that we'll be allocating an extra
79 million pounds
to boost mental health support for
children and young people
almost 3 million people will benefit
from more mental health support teams
children and young people and those
mental health support teams in schools
will be working hard to ensure people
get access to the
support and care that they need and will
be expanding access to mental health
services in the community too
i'd like to end with some good news on
our work
to tackle new variants thanks to the
brilliant team
who've been working so hard over the
past week
we've now successfully identified the
sixth case
of the variant of concern first
identified in manaus in brazil
using the latest technology and with the
dogged determination of our testing and
tracing scheme
we've successfully identified the person
in question
the best evidence is that this person in
question
stayed at home and there's no sign that
there's been
any onward transmission but as a
precaution
we're putting more testing in in croydon
where they live
to minimize the risk of spread this
positive outcome
was only possible because of the huge
genomic sequencing capacity that we now
have in this country
and because of our test and trace team
so they could identify these cases track
them down
contact them and it shows the importance
of this capability that we've built
and how important it is also to be
transparent
when new variants are found because
whether it's here at home
or around the world testing sequencing
and being transparent about what you
find helps stop
the spread of this disease and in
particular
these variants of concern that are so
worrying
so i'm really really delighted that the
team have done this work they've worked
absolutely flat out since these six
cases were first identified
on friday and found
the six positive cases even though the
form wasn't filled in quite right
so uh susan's going to say a little bit
more about this in a moment
but my summary is that this is these
things are moving in the right direction
these are challenging times but thanks
to the vaccine we're making progress
we're not there yet
so as we go down the road to recovery
it's vital everybody
still plays their part follows the rules
and of course
when the call comes get your jab
dr hopkins thank you so i'm giving you a
little bit more detail
on what we've done for the investigation
to find the individual in question
on friday the 26th of february we
identified three cases
in england of p1 the variant first
described in menace brazil
as we know now one of the individuals
had attempted to register his tests
online
but had failed to do so effectively
specialist teams from nhs test and trace
in public health england
immediately launched an investigation to
identify the individual concerned
an incident team of 40 people from
across the system
made up of laboratories logistics data
analytics expert
was mobilized to trace the individual
the team began with very little
information
as of sunday morning they had a single
barcode and a date and time the test was
processed
at the cambridge lighthouse laboratory
using the barcode data they established
that it was delivered through the dhl
service for home deliveries
the test and trace deliver many
thousands of kits across the week to the
uk
and now they were looking at
sequentially when this test was
delivered
and where this was delivered to
comparing it to other tests that were in
the system
they worked backwards from when it
arrived in the laboratory
to where they had cut which testing hub
it had come from
and backwards through the postal service
the intelligence was then overlaid with
the geographical spread
to look for the correlation of
sequential barcodes and the regions it
had been distributed to
this narrowed it down to two regions and
ten thousand
hot possible households once the team
had combined the region and the time
window
experts tracked down every single
distribution center
and then filtered it down further down
to
379 households at this point
enhanced contact tracing kicked in with
call handlers
calling emailing and phoning all of the
individuals that could have received a
test in that time interval
these calls narrowed it down to 27
individuals
who received further calls further texts
further messages
and on wednesday at 3 pm an individual
phoned the 119 service they were able to
give the missing barcode number that
they had held securely for the whole
time
this individual has been interviewed
extensively and lives within a household
that had recently returned from brazil
and all had quarantined at home further
precautionary testing will occur in the
neighborhood
and we've already started testing all of
the samples from the neighborhood
through whole genome sequencing to
ensure that there's no further
distribution of cases in the community
this is a testament to the nhs test and
trace teams
the call handlers and the public health
england health protection team
working together to find an individual
and prevent further transmission
thank you thanks very much susan first
we're going to go to questions from the
public
and then from uh the media the first
question by video
is from andrew from durham good
afternoon
the past 12 months have identified
current and future
mental health challenges and also an
opportunity to improve
what will the government be doing around
the current mental health challenges
how will they be approaching mental
health and well-being for the future
especially mental health and well-being
in young children in schools
thank you well andrew it's a very
pertinent question
because it's an incredibly important
challenge
and it's clear that the measures that
we've had to take in the last year
and the lockdown have had a significant
effect on some people
and we need to make sure that we
respond to that and support
our mental health professionals who've
been working incredibly hard
and i would say that the response is in
three parts
the first is to support those who are
currently working
very hard to deliver mental health
services
and in particular we've seen a rise in
presentations of serious mental ill
health and
making sure that our mental health teams
have the support to respond
to those cases in a timely fashion is
incredibly important
the second has been to expand the number
of people who can get access
to mental health services to support
those
who may have a challenge with their
mental health which can be addressed
through services like talking therapies
so-called iap therapies and other online
services which we've expanded massively
during the pandemic and the third
is something that we've announced
further funding to today an extra 79
million to support
children and young people's mental
health especially as they go back to
school
and this will be linked support workers
who link
schools with local mental health
services
because it's not just about the serious
mental ill health
although that is obviously absolutely
critical
it's about making sure that everybody
gets the support
to strengthen their mental health and
this is something
everybody can do in the same way that
you know even
fit and healthy people go out
to strengthen their physical health you
know i was out running in the park this
morning
everybody can take steps to support
their mental health
and to make sure that your mental health
stays strong
and this there's a range of tools
available from the every mind matters
tool which public health england have
developed which is excellent
all the way through to the array of nhs
mental health services that are
available
and we've put in the extra money to make
sure that there is that link
between children and young people who
have challenges with their mental health
who present at school
making sure they can then get access to
services so that services are accessible
to them so thank you very much for the
question very timely
and um i i hope that i've given a full
answer
the next question is from hannah from
cornwall
in order to allow shielding teenagers
the chance to return to school with
their peers
has the government considered widening
the criteria
for which under 16s are eligible for the
vaccine
thank you very much hannah i'm going to
ask dr hopkins to set out more details
because the clinical details are what
matters here
but it but if a a child's
clinician judges that because of their
condition
it is appropriate for them to get them
to get the vaccine that is allowed
within the rules um and um that is
but it has to be down to the judgment of
an individual clinician
so just just to add so jcvi as you know
have recommended
that 16 to 18 year olds who are in the
clinically extremely vulnerable group
can be offered the vaccine and i in
groups under that age group it really is
a decision for the
general practitioner or the specialist
in charge of that child's care
we have very little data for children
yet and further data will come through
from both studies in children and our
monitoring process for any child who's
given a vaccine
but this really is an important decision
that needs to be driven by the
experts involved in the child's care
thanks hannah that's a
very important question and the critical
thing is
it is allowed where the child's
clinician thinks it's in their
best interests the next question is from
vicky young at the bbc
health secretary you stood at that
podium in may
last year and said that nursing deserved
fair
reward is a one percent rise fair
and secondly on we've been hearing a lot
about vaccine hesitancy
uh in some places do you think that it's
now uh
a case that there's a case for mandatory
vaccination of nhs staff
thanks very much vicky well i pay
tribute again to the incredible work of
all those who working in the nhs
especially over the last
few months during this second peak and
it's been
it's been incredible as i said in my
opening remarks
these have been challenging times and
one of the challenges that we face as a
country
is in terms of the financial
consequences of the pandemic
and so the evidence that was put forward
yesterday
was on the basis of affordability
now of course elsewhere in the public
sector
there's a pay freeze in place
and we've proposed what we think is
affordable uh to make sure that in the
nhs
people do get a pay rise and i think it
is fair to take into account
all of the considerations the incredible
hard work of
those in the nhs which means that they
are not part of the overall
public sector pay freeze and also what's
affordable
as a nation and that's the basis on
which we've taken the decision
when it comes to vaccination obviously
i'd urge
everybody in the nhs to get the the
vaccine
and we have seen the take-up increase
i would like to continue to pursue
that because i think that is the
um that is the best way to ensure
that we get as high coverage as we can
without having to bring in a mandatory
vaccination we are not going to bring in
mandatory vaccination
across the board and at this stage we
are not proposing
and to bring in mandatory vaccination
for nhs staff
but as you know there is a review
into the these questions that's being
led by my
friend the chancellor of the duchy of
lancaster
and it will look into the moral ethical
and practical questions about all of
these
issues thanks very much uh vicky libby
veena at itv
good afternoon health secretary um there
are still twelve thousand
people being treated for coveted in
hospital uh
that you've mentioned uh how hard did
you fight
for a more generous payoff for those who
are looking
after them and how hard are you prepared
to continue to fight
for those nhs workers and can i ask dr
dr hopkins um how effective do you
believe the astrazeneca vaccine is
against the brazilian variant
well libby as you know i am a huge
admirer of
all those who've worked in the nhs
during this pandemic
and done so much and i'm very pleased
that
the nhs staff have been carved out of
the pay freeze
and we do have
issues of the affordability because of
the consequences of the pandemic on the
public finances
which were set out in the budget this
week um
and we have to take those into account
but we have been able to carve out the
nhs
from the pay freeze that applies
to everybody else in the public sector
um and i'll hand over to dr hopkins for
the second question
thank you so from the point of view of
astrazeneca we do not yet have
laboratory or clinical data
to show the vaccine effectiveness or or
neutralization studies
for the p1 variant from brazil however
as you know we we have some data from
b1351 the variant that first emerged in
south africa
and we expect that it should at least
perform in a similar way
um and therefore that we think that it's
likely that there may be some reduction
in risk of transmission or reducing the
risk of transmission
but we at least hope at the moment that
it will have a strong impact in reducing
hospitalizations and deaths
we do need to wait for studies to come
out from south america and in particular
brazil
and those will come but it will take
weeks rather than days i'm afraid
thanks very much next question is ashish
joshi
from sky good afternoon health secretary
good afternoon
dr hopkins health secretary there'll be
people at home who've just listened to
what you've said and will be
incredulous at the language you've used
this
brilliant success of taking a week to
find
one individual what does that say about
our test and trace system
a year on into the pandemic and dr
hopkins
how helpful would it be to you and your
colleagues if we closed our borders now
on the first question i think it's an
absolute tribute to the
team at nhs test and trace and public
health england
and all those who've been involved in
this search
that despite the fact that this case
was one of the very very few where the
correct
details weren't uh weren't attached
to the test itself which happens in 99.9
percent of cases
um that despite the fact it was in that
0.1
where that doesn't happen they managed
to track down this individual and i
think it's reassuring
that all the evidence shows that that
individual
and all six three in scotland three in
england
uh that we have the where we found this
uh variant of concern
followed the rules and we
obviously have put then put in the
testing uh around that and the final
point i'd make on this before handing
over to
dr hopkins is we wouldn't know about any
of this
without the huge testing capacity and
the sequencing capacity
you know we sequence uh just under half
of all these
genetic sequences in the world in this
country
because of that capacity that we've
built um and in fact i was in glasgow
yesterday i was seeing the
expansion of that sequencing which
there which we're putting in place to to
increase it further
it's only because of that capacity that
we were able to find these six
in most other countries in the world we
simply wouldn't have known that that had
happened
and therefore we were able to track all
six down
dr hopkins thank you so i think the uh
challenge about borders is that people
coming into this country at the moment
and leaving should only be doing it for
essential reasons and as you know
only people who have a british residency
or a british passport can come in
from many countries right now in
addition the day two
and the day eight tests while people are
in quarantine give us
extra reassurance of being able to
detect cases
and we are also whole genome sequencing
any of those that can be sequenced
all of that is really positive because
it allows us to find any of these
variants coming into the country
earlier trace any of their contacts
trace people on flights as we did for
the previous cases
and that gives us a lot of reassurance
that even with small numbers of
individuals coming into the country
that we can minimize the risk to the
public health and the population
uh thanks very much next question nigel
morris from the eye
nigel um secretary of state um
the pm said all the way back in july
2019 that the government had already
made plans for
fixing the long-running crisis and
social care funding
and yet his press secretary said
yesterday that you still had no
detailed proposals on the issue could
you finally
give us a firm date when your social
care reform plans will be produced
and update us on what uh cross-party
contacts have taken place
um following your call for cross-party
consensus on the issue
and secondly very quickly could i ask
was consideration given to
a one-off bonus to nhs staff as
is happening in scotland and if so why
was the idea rejected
well thanks very much the um the
obviously
solving the social care funding issue
has been a long-standing problem we have
a clear manifesto
commitment to deliver on that and we
intend to publish
details of how we plan to do that
this year i've been working with the
prime minister
on it clearly before the pandemic we
were
starting to work immediately after the
election on this
we we did engage then in cross-party
engagement i put out a call as you
mentioned for cross-party
suggestions and input we've received
uh quite a lot of that and that's been
part of our
considerations and i hope that we can
come forward
with a plan that can work and can carry
um public broad consensus now
it is more challenging to deliver this
in more difficult
economic times that is obvious and
clear what we need to do though is put
in place
a long-term plan that will bring about a
solution to this problem at the same
time
there are many many other improvements
to the delivery of social care that we
can make
as well as addressing this issue of the
funding reform
and many of those are contained in the
white paper that i set out last month
on which there will be a bill in due
course and to bring
an integration between health and social
care formally and much more so than
we've had
uh until now because that is part
of the solution to this uh significant
problem um and uh even that's part of
the solution the integration of health
and social care
is an issue that's eluded governments of
all stripes
over many many years and i'm absolutely
delighted to have been able to set out
that white paper
and uh to bring forward the bill uh in
due course
um on the um uh on the second party i've
completely forgotten your second
question i should have written it down
sorry
one off bonus for scots oh yes um the
the the of course um the
administration in edinburgh uh take
their decisions in terms of
uh in terms of how they run the nhs
and that isn't the approach that we
have chosen to take here uh and
obviously the matters of pay will will
go
to the uh pay review body um
but we have set out what is affordable
given the very significant challenges to
the public finances
next question is john johnson from
politics home
uh good afternoon health secretary uh
two quick questions if i may
um earlier today the scottish
conservative leader
douglas ross said the test and trace in
the early stages of the pandemic
did not work as well as it should have
and that he believed
ministers would accept that do you
accept that analysis
and if not why not and secondly
conservative mps including the chair of
the education select committee
have called for further evidence to be
published over the weekend
regarding the use of face masks in
schools
do you have any plans to explain to
parents and teachers why
that guidance has been issued to
reassure them that when pupils go back
on monday that they're making the right
decision by asking
children to wear face masks thanks john
on that second question i'm going to ask
susan to give a clinical answer on the
first question
of course at the start of this pandemic
test and trace didn't exist
we had we developed the first test
public health england did that and they
did it within a
about a month of first discovering about
this virus
in the first place and so of course
there's been a
program of constant improvement and it's
testament to that improvement that we
now have
turnaround times of under 24 hours in
the vast majority of tests
right across the uk we have this huge
sequencing capacity which is
the biggest in the world as a proportion
of our population
by a huge margin we have
contact tracing that reaches over
90 percent of positive cases and over 90
percent of their
of their contacts and again very very
rapid speeds
which is a an incredible achievement of
the team to have built all of this
it means that we are in a better place
to deal with a pandemic like this
than before and it's been because we've
built it
all the way through that's been a very
important part of what we've
uh of what we've had to do and i've
spoken on this podium many times about
the work
that's gone on to make all of that
happen
susan thank you so our face coverings
and face masks
we have reviewed the evidence in the and
also looked at
the variant that we have circulating
b117
it was with that variant and with the
increased transmissions
that we were seeing around the school
environment not just in the school but
on the way to school especially in
secondary schools
that the advice to for secondary school
children to wear masks in the classroom
and in corridors whilst moving around
the school came as part of the advice
package to reduce the risk
in secondary schools on the return on
march the 8th
that goes hand in hand with the testing
that we're advising schools to do to
also reduce the risk
along with all of the other measures the
schools have put into play
and this is all there to reduce the risk
of transmission in schools to allow our
children to
continue their education safely and to
ensure that we have
the least amount of rises that we can
possibly hope for
with increased mixing around return to
schools next week
thanks very much susan final question
megan ford from the nursing times
good evening nurses are considering
industrial action
and others may quit altogether following
the news that they might receive just a
one percent pay rise
after a year of covered 19. so my
question is
how do you expect to stabilize the nhs
and complete the vaccination program
without nurses on the ground well megan
it's an incredibly important point that
we need
more nurses not just the nurses that we
have now and we have a
clear manifesto commitment to 50 000
more nurses in the nhs
and i'm delighted that there's more than
10 000 more nurses
who've joined the nhs over the last 12
months
also we've seen an increase in 34
percent of more than a third in the
applications
to nursing and of course over the past
three years nurses have had a
12 pay rise and i bow to nobody in my
admiration
for nurses uh in fact you know i learned
that
at the knee of my grandmother who was a
nurse and work nights at the
at the pilgrim hospital in boston the
the challenge is that the nation's
finances are
tight and whilst everybody else in the
public sector
is going to have a pay freeze we are
able to give a uh to propose a pay
rise for nurses at one percent
i entirely appreciate that that reflects
the difficult financial circumstances
that the
country is in but what i'd say to every
every nurse who's watching and everybody
who has worked so hard
is we have over this pandemic pulled
together
in an incredible way and i really hope
that we can continue doing that
both to deliver for patients and also to
support our nhs
and to welcome many many more nurses
into the nhs over the years ahead
thanks very much megan and thanks to all
that ends today's coronavirus briefing